In high school, we learned ACGT ACGT ACGT
Adenine, cytosine, guanine, thymine.
These are the bases…
And yet… there's more to this tiny story
than meets the eye.
OR the rest of the body.
In April of 1953, the double-helix of deoxyribonucleic
acid or DNA was announced in the journal "Nature."
The discovery of the building blocks of life
was celebrated worldwide, and earned James
Watson and Watson Crick a Nobel Prize, which
they shared with Maurice Wilkins.
Shout out to Rosalind Franklin for discovering
the final piece of the Watson-Crick model,
the helical structure.
Tons of scientists and scholars worked on
the discovery of hereditary biology for almost
a century.
If you've taken high school biology, you know
DNA and genes are used to create proteins
which carry out physiological functions in
cells.
Watson and Crick's final model indicated just
HOW this molecule is the most basic structure
life -- we thought DNA was like, the One Ring
that rules them all… but new research from
the University of Edinburgh, published in
Science, found DNA might just be a part of
the puzzle of biological inheritance.
All humans carry 2 meters of DNA in each of
their cell nuclei (except in sperm and egg
cells, of course).
That's a fantastic amount of genetic information.
In fact, if you do the math, the human body
contains 100 trillion meters of DNA per person.
That's enough to make a line of DNA to the
sun and back 300 times.
Similar to a rope, it can get tangled if you
don't store it properly, so nature figured
out an efficient means of storage.
The DNA molecule carries a negative charge,
so (like my hair to a balloon) DNA is attracted
to these positively charged proteins called
histones and form what looks like little beads
on a string.
We've known this for decades, but this new
study found these histones are more than they
seem.
DNA wraps itself around the histones like
a spool, storing the DNA safely and decreasing
its length by seven times, but it's not just
for storage.
It also can determine what genes near each
histone are switched on or off.
Now, for the first time ever, research uncovered
histones can affect how DNA is expressed not
just in me, but in my offspring!
This discovery finds that DNA isn't the lonely
hero of inherited traits after all, but a
member of a team.
Assuming I'm a yeast cell, of course.
By manipulating the histones inside yeast
cells, researchers were able to follow how
that affected the gene expression from one
generation to the next.
Essentially, if they messed with a histone,
and that switched off some genes nearby, they
could see those same switches were off in
the next generation of yeast too!
Proving the histones are inherited and were
affecting gene expression in the yeast's offspring.
Histones' effects on gene expression was known,
but that it is inherited is groundbreaking!
Histones are a major driver of epigenetics
through a process called histone methylation.
When amino acids link up with histones, they'll
help switch on or off genes and which affects
genetic expression, DNA transcription (or
copying), and thus ultimately the organism
as a whole.
And it's inherited!
We already know histone methylation can be
affected by stress and diet; that's basic
epigenetics, but if scientists can show histones
are inherited like DNA in humans, then we
might be getting our first glimpse into how
YOUR stress could affect your kids, and their
kids!
WOW!
Does this stress you out?
STOP BEING STRESSED!
Its affecting your grandkids!
On the other hand, so what if you're stressed.
We're getting so good at genetic modifications,
we should be able to just go in and tweak
our kids anyway?
Right?
Julianna, debate the merits of designer genetic
babies in THIS video (soundup)
subscribe.
like.
love.
hugs. thanks for
watching dnews.